this next panel and this next segment of
the day opens up our gaze onto the world
keeping as the center of gravity the the
the focus on systems and prototypes and
the interconnectedness Not only of
Crisis but also of actions that we can
start to actually tackle this crisis I
would like to introduce this panel
designed by systems it's a really
interesting panel that is composed of
different uh different proficiencies and
different expertise we have one some who
is one of the founding partners of woha
a company an architectural company that
is very dear and very known to all of
you they founded it in 1994 here in
Singapore and what they try to do
through their projects is to insert
Active Components that participate in
larger Urban and natural systems I have
picked from the biographies what was
convenient for me so it's really you
know so that I can make the point second
will come
is beautiful an environmental
gerontologist which means somebody that
is trying to really think of the Aging
population that is all of us because
we're all aging and try to really make
sure that their experience is our
experience so that there is an
integration in the territory of all ages
because the Aging population is growing
now that's something that also the other
designers and architects in the panel do
so it's going to be interesting to see
how everybody tackles it differently
Stephen Cairns is a designer an author
an educator and even in his case
beautiful area of expertise agropolitan
territories the integration of urban and
rural and actually more than the
integration also the co-participation
and the co-design that the two Fields
can have and then last but not least
who is an expert of sustainability
projects and policies in Asia and who
works with many different agencies
besides also teaching on this particular
subjects so I would like to call on
stage first month some please well here
you are thank you welcome see everybody
loves you you're a rock star too
good afternoon
this is a short talk is about form
follow systems part one is about
building scale two projects as
prototypes with system thinking approach
and part two will be done by normal
we'll talk about impact of scaling up to
neighborhoods and districts as part of
our research by Design in our integrated
sustainable design Master Studio at nus
Skyview at Dawson is a 50-story public
housing project this is about
densification high-rise high density
High amenity but also about human scale
focusing on community
plan three-dimensionally with a matrix
of Sky Villages and multiple ground
levels
on the right through a series of
pictorial you see how the sky Villages
are organized on the railground level
mature trees are kept as a park
80 homes 10 stories make one sky village
Diamond shaping plan apartments one unit
thick three scalloped Villages are
connected side by side
another layer of Sky religious is
stacked on the open courtyard of the
diamond plan enables a vertical
Breezeway which makes it possible to
have a vertical hot air movement and
effecting good cross ventilation to all
apartments
yet another layer of Sky Villages are
stacked on every row of Sky Villages is
connected and making it possible to have
a 200 meter long Sky Park
resulting in many different paths you
can take to visit your neighbors without
ever coming down back to the ground
the fourth and final layer in theory we
can keep stacking Sky Villages and
increased density
on the left is the real photograph of
the layering of Sky parks
on the left is again another image of a
photograph of this Village Green of one
of the sky villages
and you can see and hear when you walk
home through this language to the
apartments
on the right is a short section of the
overall of the building overall 960
homes 12 Sky Villages a park on the
ground floor ground level with a
neighborhood Square four tiers of Sky
Parks all accessible to the public at
all times including the top most which
we call it the penthouse park for the
people
topping the buildings the store canopy
harvesting enough clean energy to power
all the public amenities
post-occupation surveys conducted
highlighted some interesting findings
that validated some of these strategies
18 of savings in the energy bills due to
the good cross ventilation
3.5 times more visitors is counted in
the sky parks
and 1.3 times number of neighbors
considered as friends
the second project is kampong admittee
this is another public housing
development but for the Elderly with
mixed users the focus is on the elderly
within the community and being
biocentric
is dislocated centrally in the
neighborhood center
and connects to the MRT making it
convenient for the elderly to assess all
parts of Singapore you can see the MRT
on the right and the building stepping
up as a park shooting against the noise
from the MRT
we took a club sandwich approach putting
together synergistic outcomes
first and second level of the covered
Plaza and the community as the community
living room and Hawker Center as a
comedy dining room
level three to five we located the
medical center and the first units of
elderly housing
from level five to eight is an elevated
and stepping Park and within our daycare
facilities and amenities for the young
and old
on the very top the comedy Park a
community Farm to encourage active and
healthy lifestyle
the stepping and cascading landscape
show us an important vertical Implement
a vertical phyton remediation and
Detention of rain water same time
creating waterfalls and bodies for an
enjoyment of the users
what is interesting is that when we call
the biodiversity survey we realized that
as compared to a park on the ground
level even as a building come from Amity
has 17 animal species more compared to
the park next door
and in terms of the ecosystem Services
what is also interesting is that the
Landscaping the development
even though the building is occupied
almost full site coverage provides about
20 percent of the ecosystem Services as
compared to a low land rainforest
recording air quality water runoff and
reducing solar heat reduction
it is hard to describe kampung at
routine totally but maybe a short video
we should do a better job
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
as their member numbers are growing
rapidly
for too often aging is viewed simply as
a process of decline the growth that a
company is aging invisible to society
as a result Elders are effectively cut
off from the flow of daily life with us
the wisdom and perspective lost to the
children and younger adults in their
community
12 years ago I have found a ipasio which
is a principle-based approach
developed to challenge the privilege
mostly negative perception about aging
by empowering Elders to co-create
physical place where they can contribute
to community our community members for
all ages rather than being taken care of
so this is the pictures that
came from a project one is from Japan
and Nepal and Philippines when I give a
lecture sometimes people of people are
surprised that I don't have a very sad
older person's pictures
um
because
this to me it is a question I try to ask
what does good living in older age mean
to you there are lots of othering
happening in our society other people
are them person with dementia are
someone else but you know aging is
something that none of a Human Being
Human kind actually
avoid it we all go into face that you
know are you a happy businessing home
are you happy with Assisted Living are
you happy with adult day Center
if you're not waiting around does not
change anything so what can we do
so this is the this slide actually
captures what we want to do through
ibasho and it's not only Basho but I
would like to envisionally imagine
this one it says the time to be happy is
now the place to be happy is here
the way to be happy is to make other
people happy
I found this quote in elementary school
in Bhutan actually when I was working on
senior housing project for bhutanese
monks which I didn't think that they
were going to retire but there is a
retirement age in Bhutan for monks this
quote actually very much resonated with
me because it captured the gap between a
current approach of care
which is to look after other people as
if they are social liabilities
um everybody wants to be and also the
gap between the current approach of care
and what elders and we want when we get
older
everyone wants to be useful to others
regardless of the age physical and
cognitive abilities it really resonates
to me in this one and however the
current system treat Elders as a people
for whom we have to care rather than
treating them as the people who can
actually contribute to our community and
teach us something
so about your approach recognize Elders
as a variable asset to their Community
empowering them to be change agent Who
challenged social perception and change
the narrative from negative to positive
so I actually wrote down this letter a
little comment when I went on the diary
that when I saw this how can each of us
be a part of co-designing shared future
for elders across globe
in which aging is not something to fear
but to but an opportunity to appreciate
potential within us all for Meaningful
growth throughout our lives
so this is a IBA shows pictures that I
worked with in Japan this is a reality
of modern society other people
exercising children sitting in the bench
and playing video game
but it's important message here is that
our social policy has not been Rewritten
to adopt these issues because we still
try to protect the older person from
younger generation but other people are
different so what can we do to change it
so these are the eight principles that
we came up with this is a principle base
so that it can be applied to other
places
um it's very simple it's just repetitive
it's a it's kind of repeated common
sense but sometimes Common Sense has to
be repeated
so principle one is all the wisdom you
know other people are variable asset
principle two no one wants to go to the
institution but the normal place like
coffee shop and principle three the
marginalization of residents participate
you don't want to be in the middle of
nowhere with the green space we want to
be in red action is and Community
ownership you know older people can
actually own this and run it and the
principle number five other people don't
want to be around other people all the
time and it has to be a culturally
appropriate that laughing means that you
probably agree on this right and as a
principle seven is that you know just
Community has to be environmentally
socially and economically sustainable so
that program sustained within the hands
the last one is embracing imperfection
in Japanese we call it the wabi-sabi the
real Beauty a lie lie in the
imperfections you know we if we just try
to wait until a perfect moment that
doesn't happen why don't we just try
doing something improve it from there
that's where the um beauty lies so what
makes ibasho it's ibasho it's just
basically try to adapt the a principle
and those activities shouldn't be to
look after other people and the place
should be designed by the older people
and they keep changing so opening day is
not the first I mean the last day
of to change Elders that keep changing
and the process has to be really elderly
LED and really Elders has to take a
leadership to tell us what they want to
do so these are the places that we
created this is in Japan uh three places
that I worked with was happened to be
um post-disaster area so this is in
Philippine this is uh Nepal
so now I'm involved in the health
district project in Queenstown
um so what we try to do is to have a
really bring a co-chair of three
agencies to bring a
um that Wellness rather than Health Care
Focus
so I just wanted to bring all these two
slides up because it is
just to say it's just integration of
agency is important but I like to live
live with design implication based on my
30 years of design experience
if we put just try to design the
building that protects Elders that might
create dependency if you're not careful
and if we try to provide special service
for elders that might create the ageism
specially designed service and built
environment May create stigma
a specific design
creates segregation
excessive convenient technology might
create social isolation I really like to
leave this question for you how we can
design with other people to be able to
create the space where we want to age
thank you so much
[Applause]
wow thank you Amy that was really really
important and now on the stage Stephen
Cairns foreign
[Applause]
hello everybody it's a great pleasure to
be here my name is Stephen Cairns um and
I'd like to bring together three main
themes uh in my talk I'd like to think
about Food Systems I'd like to think
about food waste and I'd like to think
about how black soldier Flies who I'll
introduce you to in a moment can help us
in upcycling that food waste and finally
I'd like to think about those three
themes specifically what it means to be
in the city
foreign
food future systems we probably know
this already this is a very significant
theme for sustainable cities worldwide
but it has practical relevance right
here in Singapore because the Singapore
food agency has adopted an ambitious and
very impressive policy to produce 30
percent of the of Singapore's
nutritional needs by 2030 domestically
and further for those of you who know
this field that statistic is going from
a base of around about zero percent
currently most of Singapore's food as
you know is already imported so to prove
from that very low number up to 30
percent uh by 2030 is a serious ambition
you might also um see from from that
title that most of the focus of that
policy ambition will be on the
production of food so it's bringing
production of food into the city already
super interesting and super complicated
question and we've seen examples of that
how that's already been achieved and
experimented with however if you think
about the second statistic that 40
percent of total world food production
is currently wasted
then there's another dimension that we
have to think alongside production and
of course this is the management of food
waste and they go very very close
together hand in hand
a couple of footnotes here the wealthier
the city the higher the food waste so I
suspect 40 is relatively conservative
for cities like Singapore
so my main hypothesis here that future
Food Systems need tighter circularity to
achieve and support the aims of the
Singapore food agency and of course to
support the aims of the sustainable
development goals and all the other kind
of global and Regional policy Frameworks
that we're very familiar with
let me change tack a little bit here um
let's imagine uh one of the nastiest one
of the most generic pieces of food that
we probably consume guiltily and this is
the hamburger the hamburger is highly
processed food and let's think about it
entering the food system of course the
wheat has to be harvested to produce the
bread the meat has to be harvested to
produce the filling there are typically
gherkins there is there are onions in
there as well there are sesame seeds
perhaps on top of the bun and of course
there are sugars and salts and all kinds
of preservatives kind of mixed into that
so in this in this simple diagram of of
a food system you can imagine
um
the Assembly of the bun in the
production process the processing sorry
the production phase the processing very
sophisticated logistical system to bring
that hamburger to your table whether
it's at a at a restaurant or or
delivered delivered to you at your door
and of course the consumption process
that happens in that now at 40 percent
figure that I mentioned earlier you can
see peeling off that process so there's
wasted every point along the way but I
draw your attention to the human
utilization the point of consumption is
where most of that waste happens whether
it's the restaurant the Hawker Center or
your home
so this tighter circularity is really
significant uh kind of concept
this is of course the aspiration is how
do we close that Loop how to produce
that Tighter circularity and what we're
interested in is how we can in a way
distribute reduce that 40 percent but
also bring most of that what you've sent
back into one or other of those phases
in that in that food system
a couple of other things to mention
while this diagram is up I said this is
very significant for the city and this
is another kind of diversionary a
footnote
in this kind of system diagram most of
this process is happening outside of the
city the production maybe the
distribution is into the City and
certainly the waste the city is really
primarily historically and
conventionally a space of consumption
and of course now that's changing
because we're thinking about production
manufacturing as well as food back into
the city
um so most of that's outside of the city
and this is also historically outside of
the city and the reasons are obvious uh
when food breaks down it's smelly it
rots it falls apart it's unsightly and
we are in a way we stigmatize that that
aspect of the food production so we're
very serious about trying to get hold of
all of these points in the compass and
bringing them back to the city and think
what it means to reintegrate those
processes into the city
now let me introduce you to the hero of
my story uh this is the black soldier
fly the black soldier fly uh I think
you'll be pleased to know is endemic to
Singapore endemic to Tropical regions
but doesn't typically interact with
human life so you probably do not see
these around your home but they're part
of the kind of fabric the ecosystem of
Singapore
um and they're very important because
um especially the larvae you'll see in a
moment
um is is voracious voraciously consumes
human food and is a really important uh
uh agent of bioconversion and therefore
becomes a very important design agent in
in this story of the food system design
so let's go back to our hamburger
remember I I introduced you to the
beginning as one point of entry into
this and I'm going to give you a little
snapshot of
um
black soldier flies larvae this is the
real hero of the story of course on mass
as you can see they're pulling apart
this this imaginary hamburger I know
you've probably had your tea and dinner
is very far away so you can the the
organizers are politely slotted me in
the middle here but you can see the
wheat is being pulled apart the bun is
being pulled apart the the gherkins are
gradually going to dissolve eventually
the meat also gets consumed in this
process as well this is a 48 hour period
I won't subject you to all of it but I
think you you get the gist but the
really important thing here is that
larvae themselves are already part of a
food system they're already being
consumed by chickens and fish naturally
so to leverage on that process and to
reintegrate them they also become a very
important part of that of that closing
of that Loop and of course the the the
casings or or to be more discreet about
the excrement of these these larvae are
also nutrient rich and produces a very
very important part of the fertilizers
those are three different different
practical ways in which the black
soldier fly can help close that close
that Loop the bottom edge of that
diagram
okay something about perhaps a little
bit more familiar to you as I'm an urban
designer and I'm working with a number
of colleagues and we would like to think
quite practically what do you do with
that what do you do with that process in
the city given that we know
theoretically it's very very important
and very very valuable and directly
relevant to the the policy aims of the
Singapore food agency so the first thing
we'd like to do is to think about the
conventional model this is on the edge
of town this is the massified condition
on the edge of town very effective
already being done but probably most
conservative the second what if we
brought those black soldier flies to
Hawker Center's sites of existing
existing production of existing
consumption of food this is a super
interesting possibility I think and then
finally what would happen if we
distributed the black soldier flies
facilities to sites where food will be
consumed on occasion special events
special sites for example through the
life cycle the seasonality of the city
for example so these are three different
models that will working on and just to
conclude
you've seen some of the slides from Emmy
about the incredible number of
Institutions and people that have to
come together to make these things work
I'm not going to name everybody here but
I want you just to catch the
institutions I want to flag especially
Professor nalini purnia murti who is a
biological scientist she specializes in
black soldier fly reproduction and I'm
especially proud that she connected with
me and as a designer I've been invited
into the special circle of scientists
I'm very proud of that and just on on
your left you'll see insect engineering
environment environmental impact food
safety nutrition industries of course
communities and then a whole range of
other kind of industrial design
processes alongside Urban Design and I'd
be really excited to talk to you more
about our experience about experiences
about that process but in the meantime
don't forget the soldier fly don't
forget the soldier fly as an agent of
design in the city thank you very much
yeah we're ready for the soldier flies
thank you Stephen and now near Ma
krishnani
thank you Paula
um
very happy to be here I'm gonna pick up
very quickly from where mansom left off
he talked about systems thinking and 3D
planning at the building scale I'm going
to talk about that speculatively at the
urban scale Manson and I are called
program directors of the MSC program in
the US
the focus in the program is design
research we explore a better structures
of relationships wherein many systems
Energy Water Mobility operating at
multiple scales function together in a
mutualistic manner uh
the research looks at systems thinking
in the context of Singapore where it's
applied to land use and planning so we
ask what do words like resilience mean
what is the role of architectural form
and urban form I'm going to illustrate
this with the sunachado industrial
estate which is an aging
um
estate to the north of Singapore this
study was sponsored by jdc Corporation
so the questions that we ask relate to
densification and land use integration
of new industrial processes and business
models but also how to facilitate
circularity
a topic that's come up more than once
today so we start at the scale of the
building the vertical stratification of
programs and systems what one some
called 3D planning here is a typological
exploration not unlike compound
admiralty only maybe bigger what if we
extend the 3D logic to clusters of such
buildings well several things start to
happen we see new Urban connections on
the ground below ground above ground we
can also aggregate productive surfaces
for food farms and solar canopies
and when canopy when typologies jump
scale when many buildings connect to
form other networks we see the emergence
of new forms at the urban scale this
idea of stratified connectivity is
certainly not new we see it in cities
like Hong Kong and Tokyo which have
evolved over time often organically the
question here is then what value can we
extract that relates to circularity and
resilience
Lance scarcity is very much a part of
the narrative in Singapore but what if
planning were more multifunctional and
multi-systemic
interestingly Mobility becomes a key to
this question
seen here is the linking of horizontal
lines and the vertical such as lifts and
mover systems Urban Farm begins to look
like a 3D Matrix that segregation and
intersection of vehicular logistical and
pedestrian Pathways here the ground is
freed up as a contiguous public and
ecological space
master plan was of course Guided by a
wider land use strategy but in this
Union of form and program we had
discussions on circularity because
resource flows much like Mobility must
operate at different scales I will
illustrate this very quickly with one
system
uh
at the building scale water is detained
and recycled these processes deploy both
equipment and Landscapes to manage
deficits and excess the building is
connected to the neighborhood or to the
master plan
at the neighborhood scale we discover
new economies of scale gray water
treatment for instance makes more sense
here than at the building scale at the
Masters plan scale we discuss we have
even larger features and elements such
as Water Reclamation plants
interestingly these can now integrate
with natural systems such as reservoirs
wetlands and mangroves what we're seeing
here is the emergence of polycentric
hybrid Networks
were in production and consumption are
close to each other and nature is
co-opted
polycentric networks are by definition
more resilient better than monocentric
systems where water when water for
example is channeled to several large
treatment plants in the monocentric
systems that we have in Singapore for
instance the city becomes more
vulnerable to disruption
the line principle of polycentric and
circular flows can then be applied to
other resources these nodes and pathways
are integrated into the urban form some
elements happen at the neighborhood
scale others at the master plan scale
uh Singapore view Singapore's view of
urban nature
um after many decades of being a Garden
City uh is very anthropocentric at heart
we plant trees because they make us feel
better they make our cities more livable
now there's nothing wrong with that per
se in fact one could add to this
ecosystem Services wherein nature is
harnessed to make cities function better
at little or no cost
for example sits at the crossroads of
very important natural areas which have
been fragmented over time there is
already an ecosystem canvas here
when the conversation shifts to the
question of repair and regeneration in
Singapore it must confront the land's
scarcity question how will we pay for
this
here is a comparison of ecosystem
services that this landscape produces
water runoff air quality solar heat
reduction all with the help of blue
green systems
proposed master plan is significantly
better than the existing condition also
it anticipates the effects of global
warming such extreme heat and rain
so why wouldn't we want to work in an
industrial area that looks and behaves
like a natural ecosystem why not a
waterfront park next to an agritech
District this idea of win-win planning
has been tested in our studios in
various locations across Singapore here
is a proposal for a retrofit for jurong
Gateway
we are finding here
as in many other areas that we've
studied that a district can easily
achieve autonomy in water
can be pushed to produce at least 50
percent energy that it needs and grow
more than 100 percent of all leafy
vegetables in the process interestingly
both public space and green cover more
than double
so that of course leaves us with the
question
why are we simply doing this and that
perhaps could be a question in the panel
discussion but we have a book out that
summarizes the work that we've done with
these Studios so the SUNY study
specifically in which these topics
address form intelligence if anyone's
interested can be downloaded from our
website thanks very much
perfect time
thank you and I would like to call back
on stage please mansom and Stephen and
Amy thank you for these amazing
presentations we already have so many
of the questions coming from the
audience please remember pour your own
water yes and uh
I will start with one question
that might go
mostly to Stephen and tuner miles so
about about agropolitan and integration
of those systems but actually it's for
everyone does the density that is so
natural to Singapore help accelerate
progress does it make you face these
issues faster than the rest of the world
issues of food scarcity issue of
integration of different generation is
it fluid dynamics that the compression
here makes everything go faster
the the density
um I mean of course Singapore is
invested as we heard this morning
Singapore is invested in density for a
whole range of different reasons
um but if you take the perspective of
density from an economic perspective the
strong evidence to say that high density
is closely correlated with economic
productivity there are all kinds of
environmental benefits that follow from
that so these are all theoretically well
well established principles
the big complicated question are the
ones that Neymar and Monsoon are are
addressing is how to do it well and how
to do it in a way that
retains the qualities of a much simpler
kind of maybe Suburban kind of city and
for me as a theorist I now hand over to
the Architects because they're they're
grappling with exactly that question and
the question of food of course I'm happy
to come back to because I think is one
of the interesting elements of that
story
so one of the um the the assumptions of
urban planning is that density equals a
loss of livability that has a lot of
quality of life of livability urban
livability and that um and then somehow
these two things are at odds
um I think just to to draw upon the
project Manson showed earlier skyville
that you can think about density in new
ways that allows uh the scale of that
environment to be addressed the
human-centric scale of that environment
to be dealt with uh in the sun master
plan
the density offered the option to add
multiple layers to create a kind of a
Synergy of parts that would not perhaps
otherwise have existed so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a fault but there
are I mean obviously limits to density
you can cross a line in density where
environments become too crowded and
overwhelming what is The Sweet Spot of
density I think that is the big question
a lot of urban planners are grappling
with currently we have numbers the
average city Singapore for example maybe
twenty thousand thirty thousand Peak
density and
how high can it go before you cross that
threshold where it becomes too much
um interesting it's almost like The
Uncanny Valley robotics it's like I said
like the threshold and uh monthsam
clearly your way of Designing roha's way
is to always keep
human Wellness at the center this should
be the platitude for architecture but we
know very well that it doesn't always
happen so how often do you check in with
your inhabitants like you know one of
the questions from the audience is Cairo
is now 10 years uh old how's it going
and or is it Campbell no it was Sky
voted so um how's it going and what do
people tell you
I think we
um we
I think I mentioned earlier we actually
actually it was normal student who who
came from Spain and conducted some
post-occupation surveys and and did some
interesting uh
sort of the Highlight to some
interesting facts about it and I think
we have always been going back to our
projects not to actually look at the
physical structure but actually to find
out whether or not some of our strategy
works or not and even even one of the
the ones that we did in Bangkok to met
where it's it's already 15 years and we
will brought back
um there for one of the uh it was an
interview for a magazine or something
like that and we arranged to to talk to
one of the owners of the people who are
living there and it was it was it was a
very simple idea of trying to create a
high density but yet not Reliant Air
Conditioning which people in Bangkok
rely a lot on and that we would simply
trying to do a building that allows
people the option to open up the windows
and doors and the what was really quite
funny was this this
um this Thai owner said that when he
when the project was first finished they
he bought one but after 15 years he has
acquired 15 Apartments because he was so
happy with the apartments that he wanted
all his friends in an Empire so that
they could actually
so this this is something I think that
was a great
story that we we cherish that we and I
didn't say 41 more friends I mean you
have yeah it was quite interesting the
the in fact we were monitoring some of
the conversation going on the social
media and people were starting to
identify I belong to the sky village and
then they would organize uh events like
uh the midsummer festivals together so
this was quite uh sort of astonishing
for us where Architects are generalists
and it's based on gut feeling that we go
to them do the project but to actually
realize some of this strategy workers
it's uh it's really quite rewarding yeah
if you think about skyville and you
extrapolate that to Singapore it's a
phenomenal outcome because you take 18
less energy consumption
and 30 more familiarity with neighbors
yeah 30 yeah that's amazing that's a
good margin yeah I can imagine what
happened during the pandemic also
probably there was much more social life
than elsewhere actually we're talking
about a complex of Shop houses that our
own Mark we renovated and uh and that
our own Charlotte McCann lives in and
she was saying how much better it was
during the pandemic to have this kind of
communal spaces that so interesting
um
Amy Your Design implications were kind
of shocking right it makes you realize
how condescending and patronizing
traditional design could be right it
makes you realize that uh really so much
of what we think is right is indeed
wrong and instead it reminds me of the
so-called blue zones you know these per
these places in the world including my
own island of Sardinia where I was born
in some places in in Japan where
normally people live to a hundred plus
and usually some of the principles are
eating what you have there but also
living among Generations like not
um so when you talk to designers do you
talk to designers do you teach designers
these principles these counter
principles
uh no really I include the old I mean
designer as a part of a conversation so
they will get to talk directly with
elders
because I don't want to be patronizing
designer either well I mean somebody
doesn't patronizing command
yeah but I think uh
designing for hospitals and nursing
homes for older a person and I was
pretty surprised that we really talked
to Elders themselves but they are the
experts of their old life old age really
so I just was very much curious about
what they can tell us so
um
yeah I think
Architects I like Architects to be a
part of the conversation rather than
they learn from us you know learn from
Elders because just be honest we're
gonna all be all the person themselves
right so what can we learn you know how
can we I feel like they should there is
a hierarchy so
um I normally ask architect not to speak
up during the conversation especially at
the time of design phase because if they
if they they just propose one or two
things and Elders are I mean the
Community member said okay if the
designer said that's the solution maybe
we should but you know I asked
Architects to not speak up just take
notes then people will be able to give
enough information for them to be able
to design it's interesting because it's
about changing not only behaviors but
cultures and this also leads me to
speaking with Stephen about the fact
that you warn us about showing us the
larva is in the burger which is very
funny because maybe because I love
insects and I'm used to Mary oxman I
mean I've been playing with narys
silkworms and so
um I find it kind of nice right so
um can you see that happen like a hawker
Center that has all the Hawkers there
and then there's like the big bin with
the larvae and kids are like oh my god
look do you see that happen I mean I'm
saying I know that it sounds facetious
but I'm thinking about it seriously
right yeah can you see that happen
really our pet larvae helping us getting
rid it's one of our main hypotheses so
so we we want to I mean I'd be very
interested to know how you think about
this hypothesis but we have um secured
the research program for about three
years so we have three years to come
back to you and answer that question but
I let you know that it is absolutely our
aspiration to to demonstrate how it can
be possible technically spatially
programmatically
and maybe aesthetically to come back to
you yeah to your question about me
warning you I I thought about it I could
just flick that slide and straight away
you'd be having kind of larvae consuming
a bun on screen but
I I happen to believe there was some
discussion this morning about about
Waste Systems which I thought was very
interesting but a lot of the aesthetic
discussions were always about Contra
waste so the Aesthetics was always
defined in relation to form and beauty
and and elegance
but Aesthetics is bigger than that
Aesthetics and maybe this is what you're
getting at but yeah Aesthetics can can
grapple with with the marginal and and
even the ugly so Aesthetics is a much
broader category and I I think one of
the aspects that we need to we need to
think about and by the way this is not a
research question but I'm very
interested
um would be in what respect do we have
to change our aesthetic sort of profile
as as as as Urban residents to start to
become more hospitable to processes that
are not elegant and and inherently
beautiful well that was Emil was talking
about imperfection before but I also
think that the opposite of beautiful is
not ugly but lazy or indifferent yeah
exactly so uh yeah but the one I
completely get and I I desperately
wanted to come back to that question as
well so well I I'm curious because I'm
involved in uh you know just more
sustainable Hospital operation just try
to reduce you know all this waste
because the food waste is very big in
hospital
so I was wondering if that approach is
that people will probably ask questions
about hygienic issues
I mean I'm not an expert in this area
but I know that black soldier flies are
not inherently Vector disease-based it's
not a disease vector
it looks like flies it looks like
excrement and it is excrement but it's
behaving completely differently in
relation to human Public Health
so it's quite remarkable that this again
that's why I come back to the question
of Aesthetics because
um there is no inherent definition of
that condition yes it's ugly yes it's
it's a bit squeamish but it that doesn't
necessarily transpose onto being a
public health risk
um and in fact it is one of our research
questions as to how to think about
institutions uh like hospitals where of
course lots and lots of food is being
produced and consumed and actually when
you were rehearsing yesterday you also
spoke about the black soldier Flyers
being Halal and all of us was like how
do you what do you mean how do you make
that happen right yeah
take that into consideration well I can
say it's one of our research questions
there you go and let me just flesh out
as an academic we're always interested
in research questions but the question
would be what happens if the food is not
separated Halal and non-halah
does it become uh in a way do we set
back the clock biologically speaking and
culturally speaking once that's been
through the kanalabi process in other
words does that food produce Halal food
in the end or not and that's an open
question so it's a cultural question
technical question and design questions
exactly great so mansan one of the
questions that asks could you speak to
why Singapore hasn't continued to build
similar Sky villages
if there was one of the questions the
song
it's gonna start stop no no
[Music]
we were discussing earlier why why did
some of the experiments that were done
in Singapore not implemented uh-huh I
think maybe it's
Skyview maybe not sort of
scaled up but come home Emoji is I can't
keep your mind yeah
decided to scale up not scale up but
actually to create more of this in the
other neighborhoods I think that was
political politically very successful
Paramount because it was about public
spaces and it was about how the economy
could use the spaces and every MP said I
wanted one of them in my bed oh really
oh okay
Dawson maybe the feedback wasn't coming
it wasn't coming back to thank you hdb
or to the MPS sufficiently that they
would demand to have something like that
because I think that's that it's um
the topic is a little bit more removed
from
from a sort of immediate feedback what
are the implications and how hard it is
to create a health district in Singapore
uh it's not easy
so okay so um so there is uh so nus nuhs
and hdb
started to create a district level of
intervention for really a population
Health level of you know just bringing
more well-being to the population and
also allow people to age in place and
really reduce
the nursing home usage so people can
actually live in the district
healthy and they will choose we are
hoping with the technology preventative
health built environment to really
encourage people to make healthier
choices healthier Behavior choices
making you know decision making process
so that the district level of health is
going to be changed so um hdb and we are
working working with hdb to change the
environment so that people it's simple
example will be you just increase
workability so people walk more to
maintain their health and we are
bringing technology so that people can
assess their own health and we're just
so rather than just try to move into
disease Focus so we're going to go and
help you to fix it why don't we just
take a different approach to say how can
we prevent people's disease so that it's
much more preventative healthy
level of
multi-sectorial motor Ministries kind of
approach and I actually moved from
Washington DC to Singapore because I was
very taken by that idea of District
level of you know making this change in
Singapore so we're talking about the
density issues you know Singapore has a
density can be positive and negative but
I think from Healthcare Providers Health
providing and also Aging in place
perspective it is a huge benefit people
can stay at the hdb a state because it's
high density if it's rural area it's
very hard
you just kind of read my mind because
you talked about Washington DC and I
kept as I listened to you I keep
thinking of New York and I'm like
accepting imperfection yeah right you
know like wellness-based districts I
mean I was thinking yeah we have
something to learn here so a question
question for you and your mom how do you
completely done a lot of Consulting and
policy making how do you convince other
systems particularly corporations of the
systems that you are advocating where
the benefits are intangible and Beyond
profits or losses and especially long
term which is not in the question but
it's one of the it's always in the back
of my mind
I think there are
benefits that are Financial
there are I've done research on
regenerative projects in Asia and many
of them start off by restoring
ecological systems and that seems to be
a upfront cost that has no dividends but
the long-term implication is that it
raises the value of the asset it raises
the percept perception the public
perception of what that Corporation is
selling here I'm talking about real
estate developers so I think it's a
question of the time scale against which
this discussion is set if if the idea is
that you're going to make money in five
years and get out of the project then
that's a hard sell but if you take a
longer time scale then that transforms
what values you what your values you
acquire from that system and I think the
Holy Grail of this conversation is about
understanding the interchangeability of
capitals so we talk about different
growths of different capitals natural
capital and social capital
there's a lot of research that's
happening in this field about how human
capital for example translates the
financial Capital if you have a
biophilic environment how does that
affect Health
um in the long run and how does that
translate to National healthcare costs
if you have natural capital for example
parts and nature natural spaces how that
translate to productivity or happiness
of people the sociability of that
environment there are all these
conversations taking place about the
interchangeability of capitals and once
we begin to understand better the
exchange rate of these capitals we can
have that conversation a little better
it would be it's it's my dream because
um one of the biggest projects for the
problems sorry and challenges for design
and for culture is how unmeasurable they
are so far and how the metrics don't
work uh combined with what linxion Guan
was talking about before the fact that
politicians have a certain lifespan and
expiration date and and sometimes they
don't look long-term unless they are
also idealistic and that's something
that I find quite beautiful here there's
an idealism that allows long-term plans
and long-term projects to flourish right
right because I wanted to ask humans
some you were saying um some of the
seeds that we planted at this point it's
almost 30 years ago that was founded are
now really
blossoming great oak trees right so
think about the role that woha and other
Architects that started with you 30
years ago have had on Singapore what is
your
um what is your balance what do you
think
what did you do well what did you
instead
do not so well about the experiments I
guess um
actually for for us in Singapore because
Singapore is land limited
um the measure is always to go back to
how could we do it and make the solution
better without having more Atlantic and
this is something I think um now
starting to become quite apparent when
we scale it up to to sort of
neighborhood and District scale
and I think this this is interesting
permanent because
um we have always wanted to make all our
buildings self-sufficient or to limit
the uh the carbon or the ecological
footprint to just the size of it and if
we could make Singapore sort of
self-sufficient or limited to limit the
carbon footprintages the island itself
then almost practically every uh if we
can demonstrate then then every city can
do that and that maybe the whole world
doesn't need to depend on 50 of the
arable land to feed human beings and if
you can start to reverse that and that
to regenerate rewild it maybe that's a
chance for
um
forcing uh for for the whole planet and
for human species I think this is
something I think we we always Hobbit
Hobbit uh Harbor sort of big ideas but
we were always afraid to talk about it
but I think um with with the climate
change we we can come up now and say yes
you know we have bigger goals and things
and I think that's something I think
Architects uh being generalists but also
needs to be idealistic and that we need
to tackle big problems and that and
sometimes you do need big problems to
solve this planetary problems and it
looks like your students all of your
students are you also teaching Emmy yes
you're teaching too it seems like all of
your students are really taking that
challenge on they don't think small ever
right do they they're not allowed to
they're not allowed to okay well this is
a pretty great way to end our session
you're not allowed to think small so
thank you very much great to speak with
you
[Applause]